after three of the dumbest months in
modern American political history
something kind of wonderful happened
Wednesday night at the Reagan Library
Carly Fiorina took a machete to the
Donald Trump alone you know I think mr.
Trump is a wonderful entertainer he's
been terrific at that business I also
think that one of the benefits of a
presidential campaign is the character
and capability judgment and temperament
of every single one of us is revealed
over time and under pressure by treating
him more like an embarrassing if beloved
house pet than a serious competitor
Fiorina Rand Paul and even ben Carson
put the Donald on his heels leaving him
with a little more than misfired
put-downs in bizarro anti-vaccine rants
for whole stretches of a time the oxygen
hog was silent leaving the candidates to
talk about of all things ideas so that's
the good news the bad news the ideas did
you know that Isis was on the verge of
toppling Western civilization that
immigration has already destroyed us as
a country that the military has been cut
so much to the bone that the Marines can
barely even tie their own shoes these
surreal assertions and more were treated
as indisputable fact by wide swathes of
the GOP field but amid the nonsense
there are glimmers of hope Rand Paul
showed belated signs of life pointing
out accurately enough that if you want
to go to war again in Iraq you have a
bush and Clinton then about 14 other
candidates an honest-to-goodness
discussion about drug policy revealed
chris Christie to be the lying bully
that he is and some candidates even
talked about our 18 trillion-dollar debt
and unsustainable entitlements of all
things but the candidate who gave us the
most reason for hope wasn't Carly
Fiorina or Rand Paul or even ben Carson
it was Lindsey Graham they started
drinking together that's the first thing
I'm a good president we're gonna drink
more